So.
Arthur.
Thank you for meeting with me.
It is no problem.
Got your message,
surfed on a humpback whale.
Came straight back here from Iceland.
Good.
Uhh..
listen,
buddy.
we’re doin a little housekeeping
here at the Justice League.
And umm.
I don’t know how to say this,
but uh
you're fired.
Wait, what did you say to me?
What do you got swimmer’s ear?
I know you're not
familiar with the concept of fire
cause you live
under da sea!
But uhh
you could also say
sh*t canned.
uhh terminated.
I think in Britain they say redundant.
Oh, whoa, oh,
I bring the might of Atlantis
to the Justice League.
And you're useful as long as we happen
to be fighting General Zod
next to a lake,
or in Miami,
or a lazy river in a water park.
So you can go off
and save the drowning polar bears.
But you won't be here with us
Waterboy!
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Aqua, man.
Sorry!
I'm lookin at water, boy!
Or should I call you
a Bobby Bouchet?
Ta ta ta ta, New Orleans.
You can do it!
I can do it.
I can do a lot.
That's exactly what I'm saying.
Sorry, Aquafina.
Oh, Aqua. Man!
And you ask anybody on the Justice League
they'll tell you
I am an invaluable member of this team.
Okay.
All right, Desani.
Lay it on me.
Tell me what you can do
Mountain Valley Spring.
Okay.
I can communicate
with every living creature
living in our vast oceans.
Okay.
Talks to fish, go it.
Also...
I'm going to stop you right there
cause I know your powers.
It's talks to fish.
The rest of the page is blank
for office use only.
I have sonar.
Yeah.
For talking to fish.
I have super hearing.
Uhuh.
So you can listen to fish?
I can breathe underwater.
Cause that’s where the fish you talk to are?
Night vision.
So you can find the fish.
If you ever want a nighttime chinwag!
I can do a lot more than just talk to fish.
Okay.
I can transport the entire Justice League
by manipulating
the waves of the ocean.
Oh, wow.
You know what else can
transport people on the ocean?
A boat.
Are you faster than a boat?
Heh, Yeah!
Yeah I'm faster than a boat.
Like a slow boat.
Way faster than a slow boat.
What about a normal
to fast boat?
Like a medium salsa boat?
About the same.
We’ll, stick to boats!
You know what?
I don't have to listen to this.
When I wield the mighty trident
of Neptune!
Sup.
That's your trident?
Yeah.
Tri?
Tri-dent?
How many dents
you see on that trident?
No dents at all, man.
It's clean.
How many pokies?
Bunch.
I tridents supposed to be three dipsh*t!
There's three.
Look, look.
One.
Another one.
Two.
Also,
two.
And the third one in the middle, bro.
That's a fu#kin spork, you idiot.
You look like an underwater farmer
who grows his own hemp.
Four out of five dentists agree.
Your trident is inaccurate!
Listen,
you insignificant mortal.
The insults
you've wielded today
will never be forgotten.
I swear it.
By the beard of Pos...ahhh!
Sorry, man.
I put up with that as long as I could but
soon as you lean this way.
You wafted low tide
all over me.
Now it smells like a bait shop
down by the bayou in August.
You smell like a third date went really well.
Ah, stop it. Stop that.
That’s what you just did to me.
But at least mine smells like,
cottton fresh mist.
Listen, I don't have to take this, all right?
I have more power in my scale d*ck
than you do
my batted friend.
You have a scale dick?
Everybody knew that.
This sounds like something
I would say to you to make fun of you,
but you're just offering it up.
You know what?
Let me speak this in a way
you can understand.
*Dolphin Sounds*
What was that?
Oh, I'm sorry?
I thought you could speak sea creature.
That was, “eat my whole ass” in dolphin.
You know what?
I quit.
You look like the pool boy in a porno.
If you're so helpful to sea creatures.
Where were you?
In the documentary?
The Cove.
Haunting!